quelle police utiliser,
tout en manquant de sommeil.
Nous avons parlé de certains des problèmes
suscités par nos diverses origines culturelles
et avons réalisé qu’il peut y avoir de grandes différences
dans notre façon d’honorer la mort d’un être cher.
Un très bon exemple de cela est le « Sorry Business »
observé par les aborigènes et les insulaires du détroit de Torres.
Durant le Sorry Business,
les membres de la famille assumeront des rôles et responsabilités spécifiques,
des protocoles comme la limite de l’usage de photographies,
du nom du défunt
et l’organisation d’une cérémonie de la fumée
sont tous des signes de respect permettant une transition paisible de l’esprit.
Ces coutumes sont en contraste
avec celles pratiquées dans les cultures occidentales
où nous honorons la mémoire d’un être cher
en parlant de lui et en partageant des photos.
La leçon que j’ai tirée de cette année est :
la vie serait beaucoup plus facile si nous parlions de la mort maintenant,
alors que nous sommes en bonne santé.
La plupart d’entre nous attendent d’être trop émotifs,
trop malades
ou trop fatigués physiquement,
et alors il est trop tard.
N’est-il pas temps de nous approprier notre dernier moment sur cette Terre ?
Allons-y.
Que voulez-vous quand vous mourrez ?
Comment voulez-vous qu’on se souvienne de vous ?
L’endroit est-il important ?
Voulez-vous être près de l’océan
ou dans l’océan ?
(Rires)
Voulez-vous un service religieux ou une fête informelle,
ou voulez-vous une fin retentissante,
littéralement, avec un feu d’artifice ?
(Rires)
Quand il s’agit de la mort, il y a tant à dire,
mais je veux me concentrer sur deux aspects :
pourquoi parler et prévoir votre mort peut vous aider à vivre une bonne mort
puis réduire le stress de vos êtres chers ;
comment parler de la mort peut nous aider à soutenir ceux qui sont en deuil.
Commençons par la planification.
Combien d’entre vous ont un testament ?
Levez la main.
C’est fantastique.
En Australie, 45 % des adultes ayant plus de 18 ans
n’ont pas de testament légal.
Vous êtes un peu au-dessus de la moyenne.
C’est une statistique surprenante
étant donné qu’un testament peut être assez simple et peu cher.
J’ai commencé à demander à mes amis et voisins
et j’ai été surprise d’apprendre que beaucoup n’ont pas de testament,
certains couples ignorent qu’il leur faut des testaments individuels.
L’explication habituelle était que tout allait revenir à leur partenaire.
Gardez à l’esprit que les lois varient
d’état à état et d’un pays à l’autre,
mais voici ce qu’il se passe en Nouvelle-Galles-du-Sud
si vous mourez sans laisser de testament légal.
Tout d’abord, un administrateur adéquat doit être nommé
par la Cour suprême de Nouvelle-Galles-du-Sud.
Ce sera probablement quelqu’un n’ayant jamais rencontré le défunt.
Cette personne est responsable de l’organisation des funérailles,
du recouvrement des actifs
et de leur distribution après avoir payé les dettes et impôts.
Une de ces dettes sera la facture pour ses services.
Ce n’est pas quelqu’un qui connaît
votre souhait pour que la girafe en bois dans votre salon
revienne à la personne vous ayant aidé à la transporter à travers le monde,
eh oui, c’est dans mon testament.
(Rires)
Si vous mourez en ayant un conjoint ou un compagnon,
il recevra probablement votre patrimoine,
mais si vous êtes célibataire, c’est bien plus compliqué
car les parents, frères, sœurs, demi-frères, demi-sœurs
et les dépendants entrent en compte.
Saviez-vous que si vous donnez régulièrement à une charité,
cette charité peut avoir des raisons de revendiquer votre patrimoine ?
Ce qui est le plus important est que plus votre patrimoine est grand,
plus le testament sera compliqué
et plus la facture sera élevée.
Si vous n’avez pas de testament, je vous demande...
à quel autre moment de votre vie
avez-vous donné volontairement de l’argent au gouvernement
sans avoir à le faire ?
(Rires)
J’ai perdu mon père en février des suites d’une maladie pulmonaire dégénérative.
Sachant sa mort imminente,
il avait eu trois vœux clairs.
Il voulait mourir à la maison ;
il voulait mourir entouré de sa famille ;
il voulait mourir paisiblement, pas en s’étouffant ou en haletant.
Je suis contente de dire que ma famille a pu exaucer les vœux de mon père,
qu’il a atteint ses objectifs
et, dans ce sens, il a eu une bonne mort.
Il a eu la mort qu’il avait prévue.
Papa voulant mourir à la maison,
nous avons dû avoir quelques dures conversations
et remplir beaucoup de papiers.
Les questions sur les formulaires couvrent tout de la réanimation au don d’organes.
Papa a dit : « Prenez tous les organes utilisables. »
Cela a bouleversé ma mère,
car la santé de mon père se détériorait vite
et qu’il n’était plus temps de parler de don d’organes.
Nous devons parler de cela quand nous sommes en bonne santé,
afin d’en exclure l’émotion
et de pouvoir apprendre ce qui est important,
mais aussi pourquoi cela est important.
Au cours de mon parcours,
j’ai parlé à ma famille et mes amis pour découvrir ce qu’ils pensaient de la mort
et comment ils voulaient qu’on se souvienne d’eux.
J’ai découvert que l’on pouvait organiser un « Dîner sur la mort »
ou « Café sur la mort »,
qui est une façon géniale et informelle d’introduire le sujet...
(Rires)
et de comprendre beaucoup de choses.
Saviez-vous qu’il faut légalement se débarrasser de votre corps,
on ne peut pas vous jeter d’une falaise
ou vous brûler dans le jardin ?
(Rires)
En Australie, vous avez trois options.
L’enterrement et la crémation sont les plus courants,
mais vous pouvez aussi donner votre corps à la science.
Je suis contente de dire que l’innovation a atteint
le monde de la disposition des dépouilles.
(Rires)
On peut avoir des funérailles écologiques.
On peut être enterré au pied d’un arbre
dans du carton recyclé ou un panier en osier
et, pour ceux qui aiment l’océan,
il y a des urnes écologiques se dissolvant dans la mer.
Personnellement, je prévois d’être incinérée,
mais ayant le mal de mer,
je ne peux rien imaginer de pire
que d’avoir mes cendres jetées dans les remous océaniques.
J’ai acheté du terrain dans la roseraie près de mon père.
Pour moi, c’est un placement.
(Rires)
Mais il n’y a pas de déduction fiscale.
Si vous planifiez votre mort,
vos survivants sauront comment vivre un deuil sain
sans peur ou culpabilité de ne pas avoir réussi à honorer votre héritage.
Pour ma recherche, j’ai été à des séminaires,
lu des livres et parlé à des infirmiers en soins palliatifs.
J’en suis venue à comprendre
que parce que nous ne parlons pas de la mort,
nous ignorons comment nous comporter face au deuil.
Le bon côté est que, si nous parlions plus de la mort,
nous serions plus à l’aise avec les émotions ressenties autour du deuil.
J’ai découvert cette année
que c’était un privilège d’aider quelqu’un à quitter cette vie
et même si mon corps est lourd des suites de la perte et de la tristesse,
il n’est pas lourd de regret.
Je savais ce que Papa voulait
et je me sens en paix en sachant que j’ai pu soutenir ses vœux.
Les dernières 24 heures de mon père ont été dans un coma paisible
et, après des jours de soins constants,
nous avons pu nous asseoir, lui tenir la main
et dire au revoir.
Il est décédé un lundi matin juste avant le petit-déjeuner
puis le docteur est venu,
nous avons attendu la maison funéraire,
je suis allée dans la cuisine et j’ai mangé un grand bol de porridge.
Quand j’ai dit cela à des amis, ils ont été très choqués.
« Comment as-tu pu manger dans un tel moment ? »
Eh bien, j’avais faim.
(Rires)
Le deuil a affecté mon sommeil et ma capacité de concentration,
mais jamais mon estomac. J’avais toujours faim.
(Rires)
C’est différent pour nous tous
et il est vraiment important que nous le reconnaissions.
Si nous ne parlons pas de notre mort et de celle de nos êtres chers,
comment pouvons-nous soutenir un ami, un collègue, un voisin
qui est en deuil ?
Comment soutenir quelqu’un ayant perdu quelqu’un soudainement,
comme dans un accident ou un suicide ?
Nous avons tendance à les éviter...
pas parce que l’on s’en fiche,
mais parce que l’on ne sait pas quoi dire.
Nous savons en tant qu’amis ne pas pouvoir arranger cela,
ne pas pouvoir faire disparaître cette douleur,
alors nous disons des choses pour combler ce silence gênant,
parfois des choses que nous regrettons.
Des exemples :
« Au moins, il ne souffre plus. »
« Au moins, il te reste les souvenirs. »
« Au moins, tu n’as plus à payer le parking de l’hôpital. »
(Rires)
Nous n’avons pas besoin de dire quoi que ce soit.
Il nous suffit d’être.
Être patient,
être compréhensif
et être à l’écoute.
Si vous ne pouvez pas être ces choses-là,
s’il vous plaît, soyez la personne faisant des lasagnes, du curry ou un ragoût,
car votre offrande sera très appréciée.
(Rires)
J’ai été à dix funérailles l’année dernière,
j’ai aidé à organiser une d’entre elles.
Il y en avait de toutes sortes :
un service très solennel grec orthodoxe,
quatre messes de requiem catholiques
et une fête champêtre
où j’ai prononcé quelques mots
en répandant les cendres de mon amie dans son jardin
avec une louche.
(Rires)
J’ai porté, embrassé, écrit sur et porté un toast à l’ouzo à des cercueils.
J’ai porté que du noir,
que des couleurs et une robe de soirée.
Malgré les grandes différences dans les adieux,
avoir parfois été hors de ma zone de confort
en faisant des choses jamais faites auparavant,
j’ai tiré du réconfort d’une chose :
savoir que c’est ce que chaque personne aurait voulu.
Qu’est-ce que je veux ?
J’aime être organisée, alors j’ai un testament,
je suis donneuse d’organes et j’ai mon placement.
Ce qu’il reste à faire est d’organiser mes adieux,
une grande fête, beaucoup de champagne,
de la couleur, des rires et, bien sûr, de la musique pour se souvenir de moi.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)